et nous passons donc à cette chronique
culture aurélia ce soir vous nous dites
faibles 7 comme chez nous ça fait comme
chez nous et on a trois représentants
donc trois artistes qui donc sont en
représentation qui seront en
représentation le 15 mai à l'auditorium
de trappes pour ce spectacle intitulé
faites comme chez nous loki là je
m'adresse à vous en premier ce que vous
pouvez nous donner un résumé de ce
spectacle c'est un spectacle public est
convié à une visite d'appartement dont
les anciens locataires entre guillemets
squatters sont toujours présents et vont
tout faire pour que la part de man ne se
vendent pas voilà
en faisant part de leur art dans chacune
des différentes pièces d'un appartement
peut contenir et à chaque personne un
tableau différent et un univers
différent
oui parce qu'alors il faut le dire vous
êtes 10 vous serez disent vous êtes un
collectif de dix donc c'est une forme en
fait de théâtre musical parce que ça
vous ne l'avez pas dit c'est qu'on va
pouvoir avoir des univers différents
variés des styles différents
comment peut-être je m'adresse à vous
faire vous dites moi comment ça s'est
passé l'organisation justement c'est
cette mise en scène n'en cadre d'un
collectif de dix personnes donc lors des
gens c'est rencontrer puisque beaucoup
sur des scènes ouvertes
le point de départ c'était un artiste de
la troupe milarépa qui nous a réunis
pour une scène concert dans un bar à
paris et à partir de là on s'est dit que
ça pourrait être sympa de monter un vrai
spectacle d'hier plus qu'un plateau une
scène et une scène ouverte
donc on a réuni dix personnes avec des
styles complètement différents
complémentaires et que chaque artiste et
sa vraie personnalité apporte quelque
chose
ce qui fait que sur les dix artistes on
a vraiment dit choses complètement
différentes le public préférera la
nommera pas forcément l'autre et
l'intérêt c'est que c'est un spectacle
donc d'une heure cars où il y en aura
pour tous les goûts
d'accord alors peut-être bon je vous
propose c'est qu'on garde un extrait du
teaser que vous nous avez envoyé ça
donnera le ton du spectacle
ces fonds oui c'est moche eu des bugs
cette chance aux gens combien alors le
fil conducteur de ce spectacle c'est un
agents immobiliers peu scrupuleux
j'aime beaucoup son bon oui encore et
oui j'ai un trou sur prénom sas quel
bobard
voilà qui est interprété donc par thomas
alors on a rencontré cet après midi il a
composé il interprète une chanson pour
ce spectacle rien vendu non non non mais
vous avez écouté c'est très drôle c'est
la complainte de l'agent immobilier
celui qui pose des tracts surtout l'air
vallier je gagne bien ma vie mais j'ai
plein d'ennemis
car je leur ai refourguer un taudis
c'est la complainte de l'agent
immobilier
je vends des futures scènes de vie de
famille à des jeunes couples heureux en
cd qui rêve de s'acheter une belle
petite maison et qui se ruineront sur
trois générations
j'ai investi dans un costume prada et
des chaussettes dolce gabbana un bon
vendeur doit bien vous paraître au mieux
vous convaincrais mieux vous là c'est la
complainte de l'agent immobilier
celui qui vous regardent dans le
en une nuit dossier
je gagne bien ma vie mais j'ai plus de
famille j'ai bradé la maison ma mère
aussi c'est la complainte le
l'agent immobilier
alors dans ce spectacle il ya une part
importante aussi qui est laissée à
l'improvisation
donc vous par exemple car où vous êtes
vous fait votre spécialité c'est le rap
ou fait aussi du rap d'impro comment
vous faites à chaque fois pour vous
renouveler
ben ça chaque spectacle ce qu'on fait
c'est qui on essaye de faire participer
public donc en fonction des réactions du
public par rapport à telle ou telle
question
eh bien on va avoir une fève qui fait
des improvisations théâtrales avec
thomas qu'on vient de voir il fait donc
il fait une improvisation théâtrale à
partir du mime des mots qui sont dits
par le public et vu que moi je fais mes
improvisations rap tout de suite après
et demain je pars en improvisation sur
ce qu'ils viennent de faire ou sur le
mot et l'idée c'est de l'idée c'est de
faire interagir les publics voilà et de
montrer des evènes des éléments qui sont
totalement improvisé le freestyle
d'abord parce que ça inspire c'est parce
que ça change en plus de stars comme ça
le public voit vraiment que c'est de
l'impro c'est le but
d'accord pour qu'on va pouvoir trouver
du rap du slam de la danse aussi parce
que vous avez une danseuse et oui donc
de l'impro et puis il y en a une autre
belle occasion bas voilà c'est ça c'est
là que je voulais ouvrir
merci le qu'il a exactement puisque vous
êtes 10 et vous faites intervenir à
chaque fois un voisin où une voisine
c'est à dire un invité qui est souvent
un
un artiste local et là en l'occurrence
pour le 15 mai voilà mystery qui viendra
vous rejoindre voilà tout à fait donc
comment la trouvez elle aussi sa place
en fait dans ce spectacle où quelle
place voulu laisser qui répond à la
place est assez libre justement le
concept de de ce collectif
c'est vraiment de laisser la place
artistique à la personne n'y a pas de
directives précises les transitions vont
êtres vont être amovible selon la
personne qu'on va recevoir et il sa
place à est amovible seront différentes
pièces cuisine salle de bain ainsi de
suite mais à la carte blanche
l'invité a carte blanche sur son texte
sur l'univers qu'avait qu'avaient les
transmettre au public à ce moment là
donc là il ya aucune directive c'est
vraiment le principe du truc chacun
défend son univers et vous arrivez à
englober le tout dans quelque chose de
collectif et d'harmonieuses ce 9e ok et
alors quels sont vos projets futurs
alors pour ce spectacle pour ce
collectif en lui-même peut-être qu'à
d'autres spectacles si on veut donc déjà
il nous reste encore douze dates sur
paris une date donc le 15 mai parce
qu'alors la prochaine n'attire paris
c'est le 10 mai le 10e
voilà et donc on a également donc la
dernière de ce spectacle en tout cas
pour la saison ça sera donc le dimanche
26 mai donc c'est à montmartre saleilles
de la butte près du métro anvers de la
butte montmartre
et puis après le spectacle évoluera
également la saison prochaine mais donc
donc l'idée la cde peut-être de le
revisiter ou avec toc mandat monsieur
s'il quittera différents mais vous
partez donc donc voilà il faudra romane
inévitablement parce qu'il fait partie
des improvisateurs
de théâtre les deux personnes pascal
bobards et fèves sont dans
l'improvisation théâtrale donc
inévitablement enfin combler ce départ
donc voilà il ya une pause estivale pour
maître du clair dans tout ça qu'est ce
qu'un message soit même derrière tout ça
ça merci à vous